welcome to episode 36 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode co-hosted by my dad
we spoke with wim hoff who's an absolute
legend
wim holds 26 world records for
performing unbelievable feats of human
conditioning and breaking barriers that
science did not believe
possible we discussed his unique
conditioning methods
found similarities between his and my
father's work which was super cool
we delved into the idea of physically
healing trauma through impacting dna
and he showed us exactly how to do his
breath work
this was very cool whim is so cool
get it iceman it's late i'm going to
stop making any jokes like that
i believe dad and i are going to be
making more episodes like this
he likes it a lot i'm obviously enjoying
it immensely
so that's super fun this episode is
brought to you by true local
the meat shipping company that i get all
my meat from i recommend
their lamb wild salmon turkey grain fed
rib eyes and strip loins and roasts
i've been using them for two years
getting boxes every two weeks that are
flash frozen and shipped from
local farmers to me this way i know i'm
supporting local farmers which makes me
warm and fuzzy inside
and of course getting high quality meat
which i'm insanely picky about
if you use code mp at truelocal.ca
that's t-r-u-local.ca mp
for free steaks with your box and to
show true local you came from here
i've had a few people ask me if i eat
liver and if that's part of my lion diet
i do usually eat some in the winter but
only when i crave it i don't force it
down
more recently i've been using optimal
carnivores liver supplement
during these cravings
and they're helping with the cravings if
i don't want to actually deliver but i
want it
so if you want liver in your diet or if
you're low in vitamin d or folate
they might be worth checking out uh
they're at amazon.com
optimal carnivore code mp i like their
products
enjoy this episode it was one of my
favorites i love doing these with my
dad and i got to speak with the one and
only wim hof so
obviously i thought it was epic if you
want to stay up to date my newsletter is
linked in the show notes and below
please subscribe if you enjoy the
episode and i should mention dad was
having a bit of a hard time with
something called akathesia
which is absolutely god-awful when we
recorded this but he's doing much much
much better better than he has in over a
year now
so don't worry and enjoy the episode
[Music]
all right hi everybody
i'm dr jordan b peterson and i'm
michaela peterson
and we have the great privilege today of
speaking with
who must be one of the world's most
remarkable men
uh someone whose work i've followed for
years in
astonishment i would say he he doesn't
seem real
uh and if you meet him we've only met
him briefly he also doesn't seem real
then
as well he's he's performed many
remarkable feats um that i would say
would have been regarded as impossible
before he did them
and so we're going to talk to him today
about what those feats are and
how he thinks he manages it so
you want to take it away michaela sure
um
so you you have your method your whim
off breathing method you talk a lot
about cold therapy
and meditation and you've done things
like injected had in
endotoxin injected into you and you
haven't had
a noticeable immune response so could we
maybe start with how did you get
started with say the cold therapy that
you teach
yeah and what if and what have you done
i mean to give the to
give the viewers and listeners some
sense of your of your
accomplishments that way they can put
your method into context
by knowing what it's allowed you to do i
know you've
run marathons in the arctic and swamp
swam under the arctic ice and
but i'd like to let you discuss that yes
um uh for a long time i was a
a seeker but any seeker becomes a finder
i became a finder of a way
wherein i could feel connect
deeper i was looking through
philosophies and debating
into what it is to feel
deeper to have a deeper understanding of
myself
and that uh deeper understanding uh
that came uh not through debating and
philosophy
but it it came like in a moment
in an instant by going after
i was attracted to go into cold water i
was not sure why it was a gut feeling
a seeker became a finder there i went
into the cold water
and instantly that brought me in a
deeper physiological
depth of myself and
it was like this is it feeling
okay so first of all how old were you
when that happened and
second do you have any sense of what
attracted you to the cold water
this is a gut feeling a gut feeling got
me to the cold water
after debating for years and philosophy
and trying out all kinds of stuff then
in the
uh at a certain moment the gut takes
over
it's there and your gut tells
what to do but we mostly follow the
thoughts
and what we think of things
instead of following what we feel
deeply inside we get disconnected there
from
alienated they're from and but i
followed that guard feeling i went in
and that is 44 years ago
and since then i every day
went into the cold in all the winters
you know in minneapolis and uh up there
in the
u.s it's also cold in the wintertime
i went every day outside swimming
or walking through the snow barefoot
sometimes
i even could stay a whole night
in shorts outside in freezing
temperatures just because i wanted to
discover
something that was not knowing that was
crazy according to the people and all
that i
took it on because i felt so good and
nobody can say hey
if you love somebody they can say it's
not good for you that person
you go so i went
regardless of what they said
and that was for at least 25 years
until i met radio and television
and then boom i went all over the world
because apparently
i had gone where nobody had gone before
that gut feeling let me into the depth
of the physiology and now it shows now
it shows
after meeting the scientists and doing
first
26 world records and so many more
challenges
outside in hostile uh a temperature
environment
like beyond a polar circle run a full
marathon
in your shorts or swim record distances
under the eyes just breath hold in short
go kilimanjaro
also bare chested in record times
go climb mount everest to the death zone
in short haul i mean that's the naked
truth of our body
what do we do when we go to mount
everest
we have oxygen we have clothes 10 layers
that's not a challenge if you want to
challenge
something in your body which is
connected to your brain
the neurology of the body the vascular
system
it's in the brain there is the steering
wheel
if you want to change the mind and the
perception and the consciousness
you gotta expose yourself to the
hardships of
nature and learn to control fear
go past to get in control 100 percent of
the brain's capacity
because we show this now in the best of
brain scans
of the world hannover one of the two
best brain scans of the world
we showed through these breathing
techniques
driven from going into the cold
44 years field work i did
breathing what do you do when you go
into the cold
you become alive in the depth you
nourish yourself with
oxygen with life force and you learn how
to do that
and then deeper mechanisms they become
connected to your wills neurology
last study i did i showed
but in a brain scan having cold water
coming up on my skin
just by my thought i could make the skin
temperature
not going down that is a deep connection
with the stress mechanisms
in our brain we live in comfort zone
behavior all the time
everywhere in the world and then we ask
why we have uncontrollable
inflammation going on and we can't do
anything
because we never connected with the deep
physiology nature does
not want you to be sick or depressed
because this is outside the
functionality of nature
in nature you should be happy strong and
healthy
because you got to be alert for the
danger
there is no time to be depressed there
is no time to be
in disease because you're going to be
eaten you're going to
die because of the environmental stress
factors and all this is the way our
physiology
works and we alienated from that
because we think we are with our
extension tools
that we control nature we do not even
control
our happiness strength and health we go
to the moon
while here on the earth we have all the
stress
we got wars we got pollution we don't
know what we do
because we lost the connection with who
we are in the depth
and uh and this is what i've been doing
up till now i
have plexed myself when i was 12 years
i'm gonna do something about this what
i don't know but i'm going to do
something about this
because i think war pollution abuse
exploits exploitation uh
all these things the the absence of
happiness
there's so much regulation tension
stress
uh abuse and over with
power and money that is sick
and i'm gonna do something how i did not
know
but a 12 year old can be very strong
it starts somewhere and it builds up
neurologically i invest it it's called
belief
but now and now it appears to be that we
found
and i'm a drop out of school i'm no
doctor
i teach doctors and i teach professors
i work with the best of them like
right now and right now
last conversation i had with dr kevin
tracy
he was in the border for the jury for
nobel prize winners or medical
in the medical uh area he tested me in
2007
and he saw me influencing deeply into
the vagus nerve
and the vagus nerve that is considered
to be autonomic
outside of our will if you are able to
control or influence deeply into the
vagus nerve
you are able to bring down inflammation
which is
cause and effect of disease we found the
answers in nature
can you describe in any way that would
be comprehensible to someone who didn't
know how to do it
how you manage such things as control
over the vagus nerve
yes the vagus nerve and the autonomic
nervous system
the immune system and the endocrine
system
all those were thought to be out of
our willful control
in 2014 i showed for as the first one in
medical science
to be able to be injected and then have
no symptoms
with the e coli bacteria which can be
lethal
it's a strong bacteria and it
it causes the cytokine storm
cytokin storm is uh inflammatory markers
going berserk
within our body because it doesn't not
know what's happening
and everything is in our alarm and it
can damage our system
that's a cytokine storm that's covert as
well
right that's the damaging factor of
covert and we could not
do anything against that and then they
tested me and i showed as the first one
to be injected and have no effects
and so what did you do after you were
injected to
to to stop two things okay i did two
things
first of all i used my mind
and i just explained what the mind is
capable of
if it is connected to the stress
mechanisms our willful control
then you can give a neural signal
to the neurology of the rest of the body
to do uh whatever is necessary to
neutralize physical impact of any kind
that is that is the real connection we
possibly
all have but i did that
then i used my will and i used breathing
and this breathing technique apparently
it's an amazing technique
which is not known nowhere because i
found it out by going into cold water
in cold water you are directly in uh uh
exposed to deep stress freezing water
deep stress on your body what do you do
you don't think you do
you learn to regulate biochemistry by
deep
breathing you jump into cold water yeah
and then you breathe
automatically like like you demonstrated
and then you've
you've played with that breathing and
learned what
i learned that through deep breathing
you i was able to prolong my stay
into in cold water like tenfold
how long did it take you how many months
or years did it take you to develop only
a couple of months
a couple of weeks a couple of months and
i could stay
i i i also did my breathing exercises
and i could stay
for five to seven minutes breath hold
that's another thing it's not sports
it's just our capacity is much more than
we normally use
right right and you're making the you're
making the case that if we expose
ourselves
ourselves to relatively extreme
stressors that we become more integrated
psychophysiologically yes exactly
okay so you you went into cold water and
then you practiced
staying in there longer and longer and
you did that
and you found that if you were able to
what to voluntarily
um would you say cooperate with that
deep breathing
that that enabled you to stay in longer
and longer yes
like and what like this ice water
playing and it was this gut instinct
that drove you to
to experiment with this it must have
been extremely
difficult
that was surprisingly not there
no difficulty whatsoever i was ready
actually to go in
i had debated so much it's like wow get
the
[ __ ] to shut up i want to i want to do
something
you know a moment like you want to
yeah you are over with this minding
about
it all you want to feel
and so when i went into the water i
felt great i'm having all sorts of
trouble
regulating my physiology for a variety
of reasons
i'm very ill and um i'm very interested
in your accounts of psychophysiological
integration and
is it autoimmune it's it's
um it's damage it's damaged from uh
medication
like neurological damage i can't stop
myself from moving
ah i am right now it's willpower that's
stopping it but
i have to move all the time
uncontrollably
so do this breathing technique because
it works
deeply on a reset of the neurology
can you show up i i will show you okay
first i explain okay the working
principle
of this breathing technique is that we
alkalize the body do we bring up the ph
level
so much like we spike it to eight
where it normally has to be three seven
point three seven point four
mostly we are below we bring it to 7.88
right and that's a logarithmic scale yes
and
and that that that is not good
but it only spikes it only spikes and
that
activates the adrenal axis
deeply they found out that the adrenal
axis
is spiked because of the ph spike
we give it to the body you will
experience it
in this uh podcast and i will show you
but okay what can i can i do it along
with you yes yes of course
and you can yeah you guys want to do it
yes yes tell me how you feel afterwards
okay we just do one round i recommend
you do it uh jordan you do it whenever
you feel anxiety or deep neurological
deficiency
or whatever yes okay well that means i
should be doing it about two or three
hundred times a day i would say
i i think if you do this then it
it's like staying away a long a longer
and longer
time but let's do it
okay okay here we are
relax
take a deep breath
all in and let it go
all in
let it go
i will take the telephone then see how
long
you've got to stay first round 90
seconds
one half minute after the exhalation
without uh without air in the lungs
for 90 seconds no force that is deeply
into the neurology
you will see just follow me and i will
show you
here on the timer that you do
so and i will talk while well
and say what is happening because you
feel it
okay all right there we go
this by the way this technique uh with
this weeb
uh change fundamentally medical
science of our perspective of what we
can do
within our physiological depth
against bacteria virus depression
neurological diseases etc
but now you will experience so
i will show the on the camera the the
the numbers okay i don't know if i can
do that there we go
so now you got it fully in
let it go fully in
let it go
pull in
let it go keep on going the mind goes
with the breath
don't mind about nothing else but your
breath
the mind is a big player so let it be
with the breath
julian
let it go
in let it go
pull in let it go
keep on going pull in
let it go become light-headed go
on fully in let it go
18 times more fully in
let it go
fully in let it go
16 more yeah
let it go
boolean letting go
13 become light-headed
loom in the body don't mind just go
it takes just a couple of minutes what
we do
to arrive at a deep impact on our
physiology
deeper than in science was thought
possible it's all here then after
the feeling because feeling is
understanding
we can talk
eight more just go it's a workout
seven juliet let it go
boolean and go
six more pull in
let it go oh yeah
letting
letting go now now comes the last one
fully it let it go
and stop after the exhalation
close your mouth no smuggling
just witness there is no need for
breathing
the carbon dioxide has been blown off ph
level uh is a really high there is no
trigger to breathe
only the brain could reflex but don't
just be in the peace it's the
parasympathetic nervous system
deep peace no need for breathing
just witness you're deep into the
physiology of your
being the way nature meant it to be
because you are right now in deep deep
stress
but you are tranquil it's a paradox
we are really deep into our physiology
right now
no force
and you changed your biochemistry
and now the adrenal axis is shooting out
through all the body resets the body
any defect is being neutralized
getting rid of ten seconds
more nine
six three
two one fully it
fully in and hope fully
hold squeeze it to your head
three two one
let it go there we are
god i hated that yeah sure
but this is the way we you know what you
hit more
this neurological defect yes and this
is the way through deep stress activated
consciously
while being okay because it's
maybe also because of the stress of the
podcast
and so yeah did we hold our breath for
90 seconds
you could yes for 90 seconds you guys
did 90 seconds yeah
it's all there i probably did 85 seconds
and took a tiny little breath yeah
that's what happened to me too
this is round number one right number
two we would go two minutes
round number three two and a half number
four
three minutes of holding back exhale
into lungs yes
you have you gotta do this then you will
see how do you feel
well i'm not wandering around the room
uncontrollably moving and screaming so
you know that's better than three or
four hours of my day
i'm still able to stay calm and sit here
and talk to you
exactly that's an accomplishment now you
gotta go
even deeper and so in four rounds you
will be able to reach
after exhalation that is there is an
understanding principle
after exhalation means there is no air
anymore in the lungs
and you exhale completely yeah almost
completely
lucky i found i found if you if you
exhale all the way and then you kind of
bring your stomach
up underneath your ribs yes
um that helps i got taught that earlier
this year it kind of helps
in yoga that is the contraction
it's all you know it's all knowledge
but this is all new and that it is true
science makes it a trust worthy
it's data it shows that we are
activating the immune system
through this deep stress the adrenal
axis
suddenly spikes while you are in control
how many breaths did you have us take
about 30
30 30 breaths and then a minute and then
and so with your with your your advice
is to do the 30 breaths and the 90
minutes of breath holding 90 seconds
90 seconds of breath holding yes around
that
and then what i advise is this
go without force
so whenever you really feel the urge to
breathe
again do it take him in
but i tell you in four rounds you should
be able if you just
relax on that beautiful it's a very nice
couch by the way
thank you so now i like the golden and
the copper green yes well she spent a
lot of time picking this out you just
had it delivered didn't you
yeah i bought it off a very elderly lady
but i love it
yeah that's that's nice so if you lie on
the couch or at home
on the bed you are even more relaxed
than the
the tissue is able to open up more
and receive even more oxygen then the ph
levels they go even way up more
and then it's easier to not
breathe what happens when you not
breathe and your ph
levels are actually okay they are great
and there is no oxygen suddenly the
oxygen drops
dramatically nobody understands in the
hospital because they saw this for the
first time
that is where normal people die we go
even lower
in doing just what we just did yes
if you do three minutes you go lower
than
people who are dying and
three minutes of breath holding yes
exhale after the
exhalation that means that the oxygen
after one half minute the oxygen drops
dramatically and that means that in the
brain stem
the the survival brain the survival
triggers
they come up with the adrenal axis
hypothalamus epithesis
gland and uh the adrenal glands womb
and then anything that should not be in
the body
it's gotten rid of oh it's like a big
sweep yeah
yeah and one of the thing is the immune
system
the immune system white cells the stem
cells are activated
the red cells the lymphocytes the
neutrophils the
t cells the b cells they are all
activated
because it wants to survive it wants to
get rid of
what should not be there what is
blocking right
so you're actually utmost functionality
right you're actually indicating to your
body
that something that something wrong has
happened
now you come in is a even a different
thing is
the neurosignal of your own will your
intention
will count at that moment it will
execute
what you have neurosignally
demanded to your body that is the new
size
i i showed it in detroit you got to look
it up as a doctor
you can look into the paper it's called
brain over body
psychology over physiology it's new
they say and that's a that's why it was
interesting
to to also talk to you uh father thank
you very much for having me
on your podcast thank you but
the thing is the psychiatrist who tested
me
they saw me activating robustly
a area of the brain thought of
impossible by
humans which is the periaqueductal great
hemispheres
that's involved in pain endocannabinoids
the opioids and the cannabinoids
the endocannabinoid system there's an
opioid crisis in the world
we found a way how to willfully
activate that area that
huge consequences another thing uh
those professors they say we found
this is the way they stated in the
publication
we now have the compelling
evidence of the key
the key components of the autonomous
processes in the brain related
to mood regulation
so if we have anxiety depression
psychosis
then something is not working well how
to bring
back balance this one doesn't they say
this is a
transformational technique that will
change
mental health care it's only a matter
of time and sorry that it is so
easy that is so simple
well it it's i didn't find it that
simple to do
um and it wasn't simple for you to
discover
that is true took me 40 40 years
could you tell us a little bit more
about the relationship
between this breathing technique and the
cold
therapy that you're using yes
the cold therapy trains the
cardiovascular system
killer number one in society what is it
cardiovascular related diseases
why because we wear clothes all the time
we are never exposed to the uh the
elements
of nature to cold to heat to pressure
it's always neutral neutral it's like a
muscle and you don't train it
it's there but it is this that is our
vascular system our vascular system is
100 000 kilometers long
inside everybody and the thermal
receptors
and the electrical receptors they end up
in
our biggest organ of ours which is the
skin
we always get it covered logically we
have a cardiovascular related
epidemic pandemic going on
for hundreds of years already
and now i say cold shower a day keeps
the doctor away
okay so how cold and how long that it
begins with 30 seconds
first i explain what you know what
happens when you
go into a cold shower you
activate you stimulate deeply
the thermal receptors and the
anti-pain receptor pain receptor
thermoreceptors
electro receptors which is the neurology
uh all connected to the skin they are in
turn they affect the vascular system
the cardiovascular system millions of
little muscles
suddenly are stimulated they begin to
optimize that the blood flow goes a lot
better through the system
that is number one that reaches a lot
better our cells
with oxygen nutrients and vitamins
that's why a cold shower
gives you energy then the second thing
if you regularly you begin with 30
seconds
then you do 45 seconds one minute
one minute and a quarter etc you go up
to two and a half minutes
a day why because that is the vascular
fitness
exercise the best then cardiovascular
related diseases
and that is also inflammation into the
heart
inflammation into our neurology is
goodbye how simple
what happens that the heart rate when
all these little millions of little
primitive muscles
in the hundreds thousands of uh blood
vessels
inside are activated optimized
then the heart rate suddenly doesn't
need to compensate
for the loss of the vascular condition
and then the heart rate will go
down with 20 to 30 beats a minute
24 hours a day you see what kind of
stress that would be
if you have a weak vascular system
in tone then it takes maybe years maybe
10 years maybe 20
but that will take its toll because the
heart rate
when it goes up it triggers directly
uh the liver to release cortisol
and glucose it's like you are in
fighting flight
because the function of our accelerated
heart rate is to pump glucose
and adrenaline through our system the
fast as possible
yeah but now there is a constant danger
signal going on
because of our weight that's why
cardiovascular related diseases
arteriosclerosis
is logical because the blood flow is not
helped
with these millions of little muscles
who are
weakened they are not stimulated and
then the heart rate needs to
pump 20 to 30 a minute 24 hours a day
day in day out day and hey man it will
take itself
soon or later so if the people they
gotta wake up
cold shower the best thing you can do
for yourself is a culture
how cool just to call
take turn them to cold
that is creating the stimulation you
start with 30 seconds
yes it begins with 30 seconds because i
say don't force because yeah
any maybe 90 of the people
go well you guys you will go well
young woman that goes well no problem
hey uh if you have a condition any
then it is because of one of you of the
system there is a defect going on it
will
boost at that moment the system and it
will go
through a good job so that's why i said
uh safety first 30 seconds to begin with
but within 10 days anybody
is able to do the same to go to uh two
and a half minutes
no problem culture within 10 days within
10 days
your cardiovascular system is
improved so much the way
nature meant it to be and the way nature
meant
to be is that the skin is we have skin
we have electro
receptors and thermal receptors and pain
receptors
all go into the skin to give us the
information
of what is going out uh aside in
in in life would you recommend
covering it up would you recommend doing
this in the morning or
or in the afternoon or the evening
whenever you take the shower
okay you take them nice and warm etc
it's all nice but then to also take the
cold water
it's the best way yeah they what they
saw
uh with a cold water we we just
recently have uh done a new study on
that
it really improves within 10 days the
cardiovascular system
which is directly related to the
neurology by the way
neurologic the the opening and closing
of
all those the activating of those
muscles to open and close
all the veins arteries and capillaries
i mean hundred thousand kilometers
is done by the neurology the nervous
system
so if any defect is there in the nervous
system
you will get to it through a cold shower
increasing
last last practical question maybe maybe
the last one
um well so the cold shower is 30 seconds
and you can you can also use a warm
shower
afterwards if you want yes warm uh
before
you should end with the cold shower yes
and then
after 10 days you like to begin with
cold
which is better why because then your
mind comes into play
because you know you are going into the
court then you connect with the stress
mechanisms inside yourself
you become stronger when you know you
are facing danger
when you face when you're going to face
a
a a force you set
your mind to it and that is what we lost
in our society
it's always comfort comfort comfort
comfort no
seek discomfort then discomfort becomes
power
that's the point where you are learning
and there you get new power you get you
go past the conditioning
and that it's amazing what the cold can
teach us
this should be known by the whole world
because now let me tell you this because
besides
the psychiatry i'm working with the top
researchers on the dna
right now next month we have the results
because they see
this as hormesis hormatic exercising
that is acute uh uh exposing yourself to
stress
yeah just for uh
it works like a bloody vaccine but
then once without side effects only the
good thing
it optimizes our bodies directly
nature's got it all so that that is the
cold
and they are doing the study right now
on uh the dna and depression
uh-huh the best top researchers in
america on the dna
they are doing this in san francisco
ucsf
professor elisa ippell yeah
because you stress you found a new way
if you stress yourself you can change
how dna creates proteins
exactly and in this case and in this
case
the cold shock and heat shock proteins
not
only it goes even deeper the telomeres
are at work
the gene expression the transcription
factors
it's all at one opera it's a big
breakthrough
a new a new mapping has uh
has begun they are going to investigate
more and now comes
the next study is with uh professor
kevin tracy in new york and i will do
this
study with the harvard professor
stanford professor
and uh the biggest uh health provider
and researcher of new york they all
already tested me
the beginning of the discussion or the
podcast i
uh i said something about the vagus
nerve
yeah which was on control i already
showed that in 2007
but then we didn't continue i continued
then with the rabbit university here in
the netherlands
and then we fundamentally changed signs
by showing
that the autonomic nervous system
endocrine system and
immune system all can deeply be
influenced at will by the human
in a comparative study this was unknown
in medical science
it changed the perspective of what we
can do
against inflammation which in the end is
the cause and effect
of say depression to cancer to anything
so i am now sorry i gotta finish this
i'm now with the latest study with dr
kevin tracy again
the professor the the the nobel prize
jury
a man and he is a great authority we're
gonna do this with a couple of more
professors
of great universities to beat
that what makes covet 19
a a a laughing joke the
information kills 60 to 70 million
people
only in the west already and we
found a way to beat inflammation
which was uh considered to be impossible
by humans at will to control but we
showed in 2014
with e coli bacteria first me but then i
said no
everybody is able to do that and i took
a group of people
and after sixteen thousand hundred and
thirty-four people becoming sick with
the same experimental model
then 12 people suddenly 100 percent
did not became sick and then they looked
inside the blood
and they saw them all influencing after
a couple of days
into the autonomic nervous system in its
immune system
specific immune system and the endocrine
cells all
systems we could not within the
scientific
paradigm control at will and now yes
and now we are going to reproduce it
because it's all natural
because it's all natural doesn't get out
because this
is going on power is going on it's a
sick
society we have to get back to our
senses
independency that is psychologically and
physically
and that's why we podcasts like this
they
they show the way yeah how do you how do
you integrate
the breathing and the cold do you do
that at the same time
can you do the breath holding in the
cold
yes what i did in the cold
that was i mean when i got a group of
motivated people and i bring them to my
center in their opponent
not there 100 people then after four
days
even people without formal experience in
the cold
in four days day number four they go
in short for five
hours on end in freezing temperatures
men women regardless the age or even
condition
what is that that is awakening to a
innate forgotten disconnected
power which we are born with
and i found a way to awaken it within a
couple of days
so how did you how did you train them
what did you do
yes every day you know you start first
you
explain hey guys there is not only more
than meets the eye
it's who we are and what we are what we
are going to experience
how i don't know this is the way i
started
and now i found that i flabbercasted the
fun
foundations of science itself i did to
so many records and i went on and on and
on and on and on
and then i caught the eye of the
scientists
of the scientific world what this man is
doing is not possible
according science but he is doing it
let's test on him
and then they uh tested me in several
ways
and they thought and they saw me doing
things
they are considered to be impossible by
science
and that i said in poland everybody is
able to
this is the way i start with these
people
yeah first okay change their paradigm
okay okay so right so you're doing the
same thing to us in this podcast
yes exactly and then and then we go
out they say okay now take your shoes
off
let's go in shorts outside there is snow
let's all walk for
say five ten minutes barefoot in the
snow
just have fun a snowball fight something
like that
and everybody has fun nobody feels the
cold anymore and then it's an awakening
because our thought
oh it's wrong it's wrong it's got to be
wrong if you think it is wrong
but if you take it on playful and that's
what i do
right then there is no thought i make it
ridiculous
this hostile force is so negative
overwhelming
called primordially uh primordially
getting to us that it is dangerous and
all i make it a laughing joke and then
you see everybody having fun that's only
in the night when they came to me
after fatiguing travel from uh wherever
they come
from hawaii to australia to new zealand
to japan to russia they all come there
and it's fatiguing traveling they feel
renewed
and they sleep like babies that is the
night number one
and in the in the morning they are
excited
but they also like oh what happened i
don't know maybe i cannot believe
what happened and that i bump
into the breathing and then you hear the
biggest yelling
of releasing trauma and i
go to the ancestors and everything
because i know
how to uh open up the closed up proteins
because of what you mean what do you
mean that you go to the ancestors what
do you mean by that
that is uh anything that is genetically
encrypted
in our gene expressions and closed
up is because of a genetical past okay
so why do you
write use why do you specifically refer
to that as the ancestors
what made you think that because we
are the ancestors within our dna
we carry every information of our
ancestry
like 13 like possibly a hundred
and as long as it is not solved it's
still within us
okay that wouldn't be i've mechanically
i've just i've just written a new book
and there's this it's not out till march
there's a section in there
there's an old mythological idea that
the hero has to rescue his
his sleeping father from the abyss from
a terrible monster
and i construed that in the book as
the ability to awaken
sleeping ancestral forces likely coded
genetically
as a consequence of voluntary exposure
to stress
yes jordan
this is what i do right now in san
francisco
showing through uh bringing back the
the primal primordial condition
of the cell together with the cold shock
heat shock proteins
what happens right you do it practically
yes
yes and you do this if you go regularly
in the cold
then you the activation of those cold
shock proteins
that are also hard because it's the same
thing
it's through the hypothalamus and it
works boom
we get connection and then suddenly you
bring a protective shield around the
cell
what happens inside the war is over guys
we can go into repair
and then you neurosignaling we talked
about neurosignally i was able to bring
a cold water on the skin skin
temperature not going down
that is how long can you do that for how
long can i maintain as long as it takes
as long as it takes that is the power of
our mind
intention it's a real undiscovered
area of psychiatry which i have uh
discovered together with professor
vaibhav
divakar and professor otto muzik
in uh detroit do you have to eat you
have to eat more because of that
no no no absolutely not it's the power
of your
intention your intention is able
this is a general universal principle
of our mind only not awakened it was not
discovered
the first time somebody ran the four
miles
in a certain incredible time year later
20 could do it
that's in the mind so what we
find is if we expose it to people
then they beg they change their paradigm
the paradigm this is what they say
we wim hof has found the secret
of placebo placebo is no longer just
over there it's now a controllable
healing force
whenever you need it it's the top-down
regulated interception it's in within
our will
that's the new size and that that brings
us back
to the ancestry so first we
made this cell protected by a shield
activating the cold shock echo proteins
then inside the cell you get a logically
is signal
hey there is no war anymore energy is
not needed to get inflammation out of
here
or to deal with inflammation or
oxidative stress
oh let's go into the uh uh the close-up
proteins
of our ancestry we can work it out now
because now it's silent now it's nice
now we got the energy pieces here this
is the principle a general principle of
nature
when you are wounded you re retract
but if you are a war you do you can even
keep on shooting with the lack of
shot that's adrenaline cortisol
that mode just keeps on going that's our
society
that is also wrong there is no peace
there is no
uh ability to retract
no more work needs to be done daily uh
uh uh how do you say uh uh these um
yeah whatever work needs to be done all
the time it protects
production your people in poland the
first day you
you have them go outside in the cold for
a long period of time with with no shoes
on
for example and they wake up the next
day and you introduce them to the
breathing
if if someone's doing this at home like
if if i wanted to start this tomorrow
i'd get up and have a cold shower and i
would i would do that voluntarily as
facing the stress okay and then
how would i in how would i do the
breathing would i do that
after the shower would i do that in the
afternoon
when would i you do it whenever you
are completely rested like
relaxed because the breathing will
open up your physiology deeply
if you go into deep stress
while being kind of okay that is the
breathing
the breathing exercises is a workout
because the vascular system is more
activated than somebody who's
running you see uh
lately i did a a a research with
paralyzed people
amazing i can't i can't do it when i'm
relaxed because i'm never relaxed
so but you can you can maybe you will
uh directly intervene
into into the neurological anxiety going
on
whatever is on the loose you will
be able to create a extra altered
current
uh within an electrical current the
nervous system i mean so
does it will be able to does it not
matter when i do it then like
i could do no it does not matter
i mean i don't want to do it with you
auntie stomach
if you need me i'm there or anytime you
can call me
we have a zoom and we do it but you
don't need me
i i like to talk with you because you
got you got a great uh
experience in words and a contemplation
and a lot of expertise and i think we
coincide a lot
like just now about the stress the
ancestry
that took me like 15 years to figure out
because
i've read all these stories they're
ancient stories
that first the core element of the
hero's journey which is the proper
journey through life is voluntary
confrontation with what is
unknown and terrifying that's the human
way and one of the consequences of that
is the rescuing of the dead father
or the hurt father or the sleeping
father it's like it's a fundamental
element of egyptian
uh mythology for example ancient
egyptian mythology
and it's it's part of the idea of the
dying and resurrecting god it's
it's it's entangled up in that as well
and it wasn't until recently that i
figured out that
the consequence of voluntarily facing
stress
is the awakening of abilities within you
that are part of our ancestral heritage
and so that is how you become a living
avatar of the great
heroes of the past but i never it never
occurred to me that
that that you could find high
stressors of a of us a physical type so
close at hand
i never i never really put that together
the idea that cold stress for example
would be
sufficient to start that process what
about heat stress
i found saunas were actually useful for
me fasting
what about fasting yeah not starving
all those work great fasting is for
mises
heat stresses or mises and the cold
stress
but the breathing really it
these breathing techniques let me
compare it has been compared
in brain scan studies of people
doing four hours of mindfulness a day
for years
they could not get as deep as a person
practicing
this type of breathing exercises
going into the depth of the brain they
could not get into the depth of the
brain even after years
four hours of mindfulness a day and
these er
what we did we went deeper inside the
brain than those people
so this and that's in 30 breaths yes
this exercise which
began with going into the cold it made
me
that's the first thing then you learn
that through
prolonged deep breathing you learn to
control the biochemistry inside
to uh to shake off the
stressor which is the cold and thus for
a long time
in cold water you find it out and it's
all based on
experience and sensation and it works
okay
then i began to disconnect the breathing
from the cold
cold i be still was doing et cetera
but then i did these breathing exercises
at
home and they blew my mind
anything that i had read in all the
ancient scriptures
i saw plenty oh oh oh
and deeper and now i found that these
breathing exercises
are able to go where our paradigm of
medical
science uh thought of is impossible
and i'm showing this now i know
you are uh practicing conscious control
over a semi-unconscious function when
you're exerting control over your
breathing
and breathing is strange because it does
occur unconsciously but we can also
modify it consciously so it's right at
the
it's right at the what would you say the
border between consciousness and
unconsciousness
ah interesting yes a good point a good
point a a
a it's a good point of view and we
modulate our
we modulate our breathing voluntarily
all the time when we're speaking
and so it's also associated with the
voice
amazing yes that that is so and done
we saw in the brain scans in germany in
hanover one of the best
two brain scans of the world doing this
breathing
normally we have a willful control over
sixty percent of our neural activity in
our brain
and now they saw hundred percent
neural activation within the brain
done consciously because we were doing
the breathing exercises
you'd recommend doing this just once a
day yes
this opens up the subconscious part of
our brain
we are able to access into our
subconscious
and it is only logical we don't have a
hump
of meat to be not within our control
but we never are schooled they're in and
then
later in life we begin to become
independent
and then you get to the ancestry you get
into the subconsciousness
you get on all that which is outside of
the system
which the natives had they were saying
i bless your seven generations before
and the seventh generation they knew all
this
intuitively then we westerners came
we took over their land we stole it
everywhere
in africa and in australia and america
everywhere
we europeans that's me the dutch
we're very good at slavery and all that
and trading
and all that and now comes to an end i
say
we got to go back to our nativeness
make sense and then making this sense
spiritually
with two feet on the ground is
liberating the captivated souls
of our forefathers which is directly
uh uh seen
within the proteins within our genes
and now we are there and i've been
talking to nobel prize winners on the
dna
about this i'm going to ask you two
questions i just want to clarify
something
so first if i wanted to start this i
could start by
30 second cold shower and i could also
start by the same day
doing 30 breaths of the sort that
you recommended and that was just full
exhale full inhale and
did you hold it yeah i got a free
app on my website it's very good
it says it all all the science is there
or all and you can
uh get a track of your records and uh uh
your timetables and everything okay
what's your weather developed
yes it's my name yeah
method.com
well you better you better uh crank up
the capacities of your website because
we're going to crash it
hey i mean with all the love
with all the love because i respect you
guys a lot
we are doing good work work to the world
we want to steer up the world because
it's
what is happening in the world it needs
change and change needs to come from you
from you from me we are here the
generations
are coming together yesterday i went my
oldest son is 37 my youngest son is
three years old
i got six children so i'm also in play
gardens
and my son and made me stop in amsterdam
in a little play garden somewhere i
i had never been okay there i was
and he wanted to play i had to go around
again
because in amsterdam you gotta go on
otherwise and cars gonna push you
yeah and so you i had to go around to
get and there i
found a place to stop and i went outside
seven children were there in that
playground
when i came to the playground six to
twelve years
they were the wim hof man with half man
they know this [ __ ] they they are
looking for something that really works
i'm a hero
because i did under the eyes mount
everest
i run marathons in the desert in the in
the north pole
i hang by one finger and up in the air
and ruckus 26 and this and that
and i got the signs but the children
know
they need a role model and i'm
real i am about love
i'm about to take ownership of who i am
and what i
am that is what i want to give my
children and all the rest of the world
and we should not hesitate there your
knowledge is great
your efforts like what you do right now
it's great work so keep on going with
that
and let's have a podcast again because i
like what you said
on the ancestry on the ancestry this
is my next i'm gonna write a next book
or two my book is doing great apparently
it's already in 21 languages new york
times bestseller
just a couple of weeks ago and it keeps
on going
what's your book's name whim the
whim of method
that's right well i would encourage all
the viewers and listeners of this to
pick that up
yeah for sure ah good good yes and
let's listen viewers we are going to
change psychiatry
because we think and we have proven
within the science
and in brain scans and in blood proof
that we are
able to control our inflammation and to
regulate
our mood we own our
own mind we have found connections
and now it's a matter of time but if you
are depressed or feeling bad and you
cannot get out
just get into this it comes from nature
it works beyond works
it's it's you it's your life force
awaiting
now it is a non-dogmatic choice because
all the millions of data we got already
happiness strength and health happiness
is the
endocrine system the health that is the
immune system
the strength that is energy the
metabolic
processes in the cell we got it all
proven
to be able to be improved
by so far far more than in science was
thought
possible here we are to be happy strong
and healthy it's only logical
wim thank you so much for coming on i
was really excited to
particularly connect you with my dad
because he's been having such a hell of
a time
and obviously i'm a huge fan so thank
you so much for talking with us
yes it was a real pleasure to meet you
it's a amazing a respect i have
for you guys and uh for your knowledge
accumulated through
uh your contemplations and uh you got a
lovely daughter
and intelligent i got also two daughters
one is a psychologist
and the other one is they are both out
with me
but that's good well thanks again thank
you thanks again
i would very much like to talk to you
again maybe maybe i'll try your method
for a month and
and then we can talk again or even a
couple of weeks and
i can report on what it's done for me
yeah that's a good idea
i think uh uh uh this was a nice
a great beginning good
very nice to meet you wim nice to meet
you
nice to meet you bye
you